I'm Ahman Middleton DC founder and CEO
of narrator and if you know anything
about me you know that I spend most of
my life talking about activity schema
it's like all I do online all I do in
real life and I'm here to give you
another talk about activity schema
so
uh this Talk's gonna be a little bit
different it's about this idea of the
how to end the long tail of data
requests
so where I kind of started from this
talk was every single tool upstairs and
every tool that everyone has used when
you get started with it it's
awesome it's like you put your dashboard
doesn't matter which dashboard you use
it's all great it's all going to give
you data you need it doesn't matter
whether using Luigi from Spotify or
airflow or DBT your first several
Transformations will be great
you'll be like yeah I'm crushing it
and it usually looks a little bit
something like this
um you might get like a classic Ecom
companies you might have a couple data
sources like Shopify clavio and snowplow
and you'll build a couple tables in
whatever Source you do like your order
dim your emails and your web sessions
and then you get a bunch of questions
and you build a dashboard for them so
you're like cool how many emails were
sent last week
today generally I can answer this
question or how many orders came from
anyone who received your great email
campaign super easy and at this moment
everybody and every time you refactor
data you go through this process you
build some simple tables and everything
looks really great can we all agree to
that it's always like really nice yeah
but unfortunately there's people and
people suck
um so what happens is that your
stakeholders come in and then they start
asking more and more questions and every
time they ask a question that's not in a
dashboard we have to do work again and
these questions the problem is the
questions are not like how many tickets
do I have because they can see that in
their zendes dashboard the questions are
really really specific
and that specificity is what causes so
much data to go wrong
so people start saying okay people that
came from this important test and they
ordered again I want to know that so you
say great how do I tie my order and
email data so you do a bunch of window
functions add a bunch of joins and try
to guess and add your last email ID on
your order Dimension and you're like
yeah I can now know when the email
happened and I'm good to go and if you
want to know the next order you just do
another window function and another join
and you might pull some additional data
build a dashboard and call it a day
and then of course there's always an
angry stakeholder who's like wait wait
wait how can I see emails that from
campaigns that never happened when
you're like oh I forgot to remove
time base so I'm going to look at the
last email ID only if it's within 33
days so that my email IDs are more
unique
great I'm gonna get there's no more
email questions right
no there's more there's always more okay
well now they want to know within 30
minutes if they open the email or not
and now you're like okay great I'm gonna
have one the email first got opened and
when Alaska opens I don't have
duplications when I join email open data
and then I create an email damn and I
add a last email within 30 minute ID and
a next order within one week ID and I
start kind of creating this and if you
see this situation you have your
dimension tables that have so many IDs
of Concepts that already exist
question comes okay did the number of
orders matter okay let's add
another column called total orders
before
oh my god did the number of emails
matter okay
okay total emails before I feel
like I've been adding this is like in
data analytics Engineers job for like
months and you're like okay this is
never gonna end
and honestly like you get it you're
gonna have so many damn columns and it's
gonna be so many tables and you're gonna
maintain it and the sequel becomes way
more messy and one of your joins goes
wrong and now you have duplicates or
rows dropped and some executive is angry
that the dashboard numbers are not
matching I live this life for so many
years and it sucked
so
um yeah just the more you build tables
the more you add columns the more you do
this the more likely you'll mess up and
the more likely you'll have a mistake
so this kind of led me to say what if
there was an actual standard where when
new questions come in we don't have to
constantly build new tables what if
there's a single structure that can
answer all our questions so I can model
Concepts instead of model questions
and that's why I created the activity
schema so what is activity schema
activities schema is something you've
probably heard people hear talk
variations of it it's really simple it's
an idea of building time actor action so
time activity and a customer and you
take all your data from all your sources
and shove them into one long table and
that's it it's a long table of actions
and it's really nice because Concepts
can be easily defined and they're
business aligned terminology if you have
like multiple data sources you just like
build small Transformations that all map
to the same activity that everyone uses
and
um everything happens in time which will
come to a point it's really critical in
understanding how things are changing
now you're like great one table I can do
count per event but turns out you can do
a lot more so the big innovation of
activity schema is this thing called
temporal joins and it's the idea that
any two building blocks in any two
pieces of data can be moved together and
joined without duplicating rows without
um without dropping rows and no foreign
Keys needed
and this is kind of what happens when we
write SQL we're taking people's English
and they're telling you like I mentioned
earlier like give me everyone who
ordered and the last email they had
before it well why can't we just write
that as SQL and have the activity scheme
do that and that's what we ended up
finding out that it turns out that you
can take data filter it for each
customer use time to understand the
relationship you want and then just add
that to the row and now you kind of do
this pivot to create a row of data that
represents any sort of question you have
and you're like is there a million of
these time portal joins no there's
literally 12. and you can imagine why
because this is the entire English
language ever before after or in between
are the only ways you can relate
activities and once you're you start
learning this kind of methodology you
realize that any question you ever get
can be mapped to actions happening in
time using one of these words if you
don't believe me you can look at a
narrator and we've kind of seen
customers from PBS and Levi and smaller
companies like code academy and all
sorts of companies answering over a
million questions using just activity
schema and temporal joins and I will be
here afterward for anyone who dares to
challenge by contradiction
um you can feel if you try I've done
this for years and I've given this exact
challenge to everybody so I wish you the
best of luck
so at its core which I stole this from
our sales team this is what data looks
like in the real world you take data you
build a bunch of staging tables and you
build a bunch of production tables that
you use and and it's like really rigid
it's really
um hard to handle and it's just like as
use cases come up you're going to add
more and more tables the idea is you'd
build one activity schema and then you
can answer questions with it and never
have to worry about it again
I'm biased because that's our company so
it's really Dynamic it's really easy to
use
um and you see a lot of narrative logos
here because that's my company but
there's open source people have built we
have an open source project in DBT where
you can use it there's several open
source uh DBT implementations that let
you use temporal joins there's a couple
generative ad companies on it so if you
use it you can select questions to it
and somebody has built a generative AI
that will generate the queries using it
so a lot of flexibility and really
growing there's also monthly meetings
about it now which if anyone's
interesting you can go to it
so what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to take the exact question that
you just the experience you just saw me
do where we went through that email
question with orders and iterating and
battle testing and changing our mind and
going in and I'm going to show you a
video of me doing the exact same thing
in narrator
um and yeah it's three minutes long
so
oh it's right here oh my god oh
this is way harder than I thought it was
gonna be
oh I forgot about this part okay cool so
um cool
so this is me picking the activity
really easily I'm gonna go around and
you can just simply see the orders and
I'm gonna start looking at the data and
just look at it over time just because I
like seeing data over time to get the
total orders over time
and visualize it and I'm like cool this
is my total orders over time but then I
get the second question which is like
tell me if the customer has ever come
from an email and I say great here it is
me adding if they first ever the first
time ever even if there's duplication
doesn't matter if they ever came from
that specific campaign and I hit submit
and that gets compiled as a query and
you can see here that there's a column
saying did they or did they not and I'm
going to group by that over time to see
if the customer has ever come from that
campaign
and I guess I'm visualizing the revenue
from the customers who came from that
campaign or didn't then they're like no
no I don't want to know if they ever
came from that campaign I want to know
if they came before so I'm using the
last before operator and I'm saying give
me the data for the last before and give
me that last before campaign so I add
that column right away and it's super
easy narrator tells me I just changed
some stuff and it's going to fix it and
then I have now have the last before
email campaign and I can visualize that
over time
pretty cool and you guys remember that
oh and let me show you the visualization
which I guess you already get that we
can visualize
but it's proof but remember the customer
complains and says hey I actually want
to see it uh if they that person had an
order again so I added another in
between which gives me the next order
and there it automatically added those
columns to give me the repeat rate and
now I can visualize that metric with uh
based on the campaign
and it continues to make sense and
notice how then we change it to say I
only want to do it if it's within three
days so I add that again and I also want
to add the total number of orders before
so I aggregate total orders before that
row and I also aggregate the total
emails before that row as well
and this is just me showing you
literally the entire experience of
building those tables dynamically doing
it all on top of the activity schema all
data prepared easily done and now we
have those additional columns we can use
and it's really seamless it makes it
really nice to answer questions for any
long tail ad hoc and all this table of
course can be materialized if you want
to use it somewhere else but most
questions don't need to be most people
just need quick answers and you can do
that with uh this activity schema really
easily and also with narrator really
easily
uh I think what I'm doing now
I'm just showing my final piece of doing
the last bit of metrics also side note
since I'm giving a talk here this idea
of building preparing data and having a
bunch of group by tabs on it everyone
should steal it for all bi tools and all
data tools so that you can add
aggregations without changing the
underlying data and change underlying
data without having to wrap it in a
select statement or a CTE it's kind of
nifty I love it so that's me doing
everything you just saw me going through
in the entire process in total of three
minutes answering every question that we
mentioned and
um that's why we built activity schema
it makes it easy and I hope you guys can
give it a try and there is a DBT
Community around it uh if you guys want
to go there or if you're interested you
can message me and it it's pretty great
give it a try thank you guys
thank you
foreign